la paciencia se acaba en los vecindarios
de Beijing ante las severas
restricciones del gobierno chino
ciudadanos se enfrentan con los comités
de salud y también con la policía
restringieron nuestro edificio hace tres
días y en medio de la noche usaron esta
barra de madera para cerrar la entrada
escribiendo en ella fuera de servicio y
según los informes había personas en la
puerta impidiendo que los residentes
salieran esta mañana Cuando bajé vi esta
barra de madera y la quité porque creo
que es una cuestión de seguridad y ellos
no tienen derecho a sellar la puerta
protestas que no se limitan solo a
Beijing también en urunki y la capital
de shinyang donde el jueves 10 personas
murieron en un incendio presuntamente
por no haber podido escapar por los
cierres que viven y las complicaciones
que tuvieron los servicios de emergencia
para llevar a cabo los operativos de
rescate algo que las autoridades locales
no reconocen esto desencadenado la ira
en la región de mayoría huigur es decir
musulmana y contra la que las
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
denuncian que se cometen graves abusos
por el gobierno chino
mientras que en yum yo donde está la
mayor fábrica de iPhone del mundo
también protestan contra las condiciones
laborales y salariales en medio del
estricto encierro el gobierno de
chilling Ping defiende la política de
cero covid para evitar colapsar el
sistema de salud cuando un tercio de las
ciudades del país se encuentra bajo
confinamiento y en medio de todo la
economía se resiente